second débat dans ce sens public il est
consacré aux élections législatives et à
l'offensive de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale cette
gauche plus radicale peut-elle gagner
quel point commun avec les précédents
historiques on va en débattre avant
d'entendre nos experts la stratégie de
jean luc mélenchon qui était aujourd'hui
en campagne en alsace est un sujet signé
samia de chiens ils ont fait en deux
semaines l'union qu'ils n'ont pas su
trouver pendant des années alors
forcément il reste quelques divergences
dans le programme de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale sur les
650 proposition 33 sont dites en nuances
soit 5% du total sur lesquelles un ou
plusieurs des cinq membres de la
coalition n'est pas d'accord sur
l'international par exemple les insoumis
et les communistes souhaitent quitter
l'otan alors que les socialistes et les
écologistes veulent tirer ce thé comment
est ce que ça sera arbitrée s'il ya des
divergences qui viennent à un moment
donné en quelque sorte paralyser
l'action de la france il faut bien en
faire quelque chose eh bien on va faire
le plus simple ce qui se fait partout
ailleurs dans tous les pays du monde on
consultera le parlement le dernier mot
dans toutes les démocraties revient tout
le temps et sur tous les sujets à
l'assemblée nationale parmi les autres
divergences les écologistes et les
socialistes sont contre la
nationalisation des banques généralistes
le ps s'oppose à la création d'une
commission d' enquête sur les violences
policières les communistes refusent le
droit de vote à 16 ans et restent
favorables à la relance de la filière
nucléaire alors que les autres membres
de la coalition veulent s'en sortir moi
je suis pour la sortie du nucléaire je
suis pour le fait qu' on développe
massivement les énergies renouvelables
avec le parti communiste nous partageons
donc l'ambition de développer
massivement les énergies renouvelables
et y compris la rénovation thermique
parce que ça crée de l'emploi c'est bon
pour le confort c'est bon pour le climat
c'est bon pour la santé eux disent ils
veulent continuer et faire de nouveaux
projets de nucléaire va très bien acton
ce désaccord ça veut dire que à
l'horizon 2050 nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur l'objectif final de mix
énergétique mais que dans les cinq
années qui viennent nous sommes d'accord
et nous pouvons avancer très très vite
sur les énergies renouvelables ou sur
les 700000 rénovation thermique bien
pour le reste à l'assemblée et bien que
vive le débat sur le nucléaire comme sur
les 32 autre point de tension le dernier
mot reviendra donc au parlement où
chaque groupe gardera sa liberté de vote
la nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale survivra-t-elle aux élections
législatives voilà le thème de notre
débat je présente mes invités sophie de
ravinel bonsoir vous êtes grand reporter
au service politique du figaro marc
lazar bonsoir et bienvenue à vous aussi
directeur du centre d'histoire de
sciences po auteur de l'histoire du
parti communiste français récemment paru
aux presses universitaires de france et
puis également les socialistes européens
et l'état livre qui lui a été publié aux
éditions de l'aube j'accueille également
renaud dély bonsoir à vous êtes
éditorialiste sur france info au
présentateur de 28 minutes samedi sur
arte et vous publiez anatomie d'une
trahison la gauche contre le progrès
c'est aux éditions de l'observatoire et
matthieu croissandeau est toujours à mes
côtés merci on mathieu d'être resté là
sophie dernière vous étiez avec jean luc
mélenchon à strasbourg aujourd'hui il
continue de demander aux français de les
lire premier ministre il y croit
vraiment ils y croient vraiment en tout
cas c'est l'impression qu'il donne et
pas seulement lui mais aussi la numéro 2
des écologistes qui est aujourd'hui
candidate sur la première
circonscription donc du bas-rhin
cendrars goal qui a qui se disait mais
enfin sérieusement vraiment vous y
pensez eem dit mais oui absolument et
vous n'imaginez pas sur le terrain la
mobilisation et les milliers me dit-elle
de personnes qui nous garantisse qu'ils
comprennent qu'ils commencent à
comprendre qu'elles peuvent avoir la
main sur le pouvoir sur un nouveau
gouvernement pour porter jean luc
mélenchon pouvoir et alors je profite
encore très bien et qui ont discuté avec
jean luc mélenchon et il y avait une
conférence de presse avec jeanne
marseillan donc la main de strasbourg
qui est venue le rejoindre qui quand
même un signe de concorde assez notable
et jean luc mélenchon nous expliquant
mais oui alors voilà nous allons dans
deux mois nous sommes prêts à prendre le
pouvoir et nous allons d'ailleurs tous
les sujets alors toutes les crises cité
la façon dont il allait y répondre et
puis allant jusqu'à s'interroger sur la
façon dont les liens
et ceux noués avec emmanuel macron
notamment sur les questions régaliennes
et de défense disant bon il ya quand
même un souci parce que c'est vrai que
soit la défense nous serons tous les
deux responsables et nous allons devoir
nous entendre sa voir comment gérer la
gestion des armes parce que aucun de
chez nous à la nuque n'est vraiment
favorable à la guerre en ukraine c'est
un petit peu surréaliste on était dans
un autre monde mais donc pour répondre à
votre question on a l'impression qu'ils
y croient oui parce qu'on va le rappeler
mais pour l'instant et encore une fois
on est prudent on est à trois semaines a
les intentions de vote les projections
en sièges donne une la majorité aux
candidats qui soutiennent emmanuel
macron marc lazar ce slogan élisez moi
s'écroule analyser c'est à la fois un
coup politique c'est un pied de nez aux
institutions de cette 5ème république
dont il veut se débarrasser jean luc
mélenchon d'abord il faut pas oublier
qu'en 2017 il avait déjà dit et on l'a
vraiment oublié parce que ça a été
beaucoup plus légèrement avancé il y
avait plusieurs affiches j'ai retrouvé
des affiches à pau par exemple où il
s'est marqué mélenchon premier ministre
mais ça n'avait pas pris la centralité
actuelle et pour une bonne raison c'est
que il a gagné enfin il a obtenu près de
22% des suffrages au premier tour donc
je crois qu'à une stratégie politique
incontestable de jean luc mélenchon de
personnaliser on le sait pourquoi c'est
dans 577 circonscriptions en fait il
veut faire croire que c'est un vote pour
mélenchon avec sa photo en beaucoup plus
grand que celle du candidat bah oui
emmanuel macron fait la même chose donc
c'est donc mais évidemment ça compense
la faiblesse enracinement de la france a
soumis ce parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
candidats parachutés ce qui provoque
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de tensions
locales avec les élus socialistes ou
ceux qui pensaient pouvoir à l'occasion
de cette initiative se présenter à la
mandature mais ce qui est frappant c'est
que je crois qu'il a déclenché il faut
le reconnaître en tout cas une dynamique
on verra ce que commencent à se traduire
à électoralement mais quand on regarde
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion qu'on a on
voit que d'abord cet accord électoral
est plébiscité par les électeurs de
gauche près de 79% dans le récent
sondage si on se pose je fais de la
publicité pour la maison fondation jean
jaurès et et et le monde
une envie d'union déjà exprimé avant le
la présidentielle qui d'une certaine
façon c'est exprimé par le vote utile
mélenchon qui a gonflé dans les derniers
jours et qui est qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui oui puis n'oubliez pas
d'après moi que mélenchon à une culture
historique et qui sait que l'histoire de
la gauche est caractérisée par deux
éléments contradictoires d'un côté de
grands moments de division et
d'affrontement terrible et des grands
moments de dynamique unitaire et ils
essayent de le créer incontestablement
d'ailleurs je crois que dans le même
sondage c'est plus d'un français de
gauche sur deux qui pense qu'on peut
gagner qu'est la gauche peut gagner donc
incontestablement il a provoqué cela
reste à savoir si les électeurs se
mobilisent on est là c'est la faiblesse
y compris dans cette même enquête qui
montre que justement l'électorat
potentiel de mélenchon pour le moment
n'est pas prêt à les voter d'un côté il
ya un souhait d'un côté il ya une
dynamique unitaire reste à savoir si
l'opa sera franchie par les électeurs
renaud dély alors pour lancer bien que
le mode de scrutin lui est défavorable
c'est un fin observateur de l'histoire
politique française jean luc mélenchon
est ce que malgré tout nous ont rien
pour vous et du temps nous décrire cette
journée alsacienne mais est-ce qu'il
peut inverser
ce cette logique qui lui est défavorable
sans présager évidemment de ce que ce
résultat c'est pas le mode de scrutin
actuel et va voir mais c'est leur part
de force c'est le rapport de force
électoral le total des candidats de
gauche au premier tour la présidentielle
c'est 31% des voix c'est pour ça que ce
mélenchon élisez moi est une trouvaille
d'avoir de communication de stratégies
pour essayer de limiter la
démobilisation de son camp
traditionnellement à chaque élection
initiative suivant la présidentielle
depuis l'instauration du quinquennat ya
20 ans il ya une démobilisation du camp
qui a perdu ou des camps qui ont perdu
la présidentielle les camps de les
candidats du front national à l'époque
il ya cinq ans ont fait huit points de
moins que marine le pen ils ont fait 13%
contre 21% pour marine le pen au premier
tour en 2017 les candidats la france
insoumise l'islate il ya cinq ans avait
fait 11% contre 19% pour mélenchon à la
présidentielle donc c'est d'abord une
stratégie qui vise à limiter la
démobilisation je serai un peu plus
prudent sur la dynamique ce qui est vrai
c'est que les électeurs de gauche
voulaient l'union il voulait déjà
pendant la campagne présidentielle bien
sûr ils en ont six se sont suffisament
plein les divisions de la gauche pendant
cinq ans pour ne pas se réjouir que
cette fois ci elle sa une elles soient
unis pour autant quand on regarde les
sondages et ce ne sont que des sondages
certes parfois dans certains cas la
nuque la nuque je sais pas comment il
faut dire enfin jean-luc mélenchon
dirigeant libyen tandis la nuque donc je
veux dire les nuits
viens d'ayew dit dean ups mais bon alors
c'est pas grave voilà c'est bien passé
la gauche reste curiel elle est au tour
de 28% au premier tour dans les sondages
ce qui doperait le score de la gauche au
premier tour de la présidentielle le
cirque mais à peu près le score encore
une fois ils étaient plus de limites et
la démobilisation et la formidable
trouvaille je pense de ce slogan
mélenchon elysées mois près ministre
c'est que ça lui permet d'affermir son
leadership sur l'ensemble de la gauche
bien au delà de cette élection c'est à
dire bien au delà d'une hypothétique
victoire à laquelle est loin de moi
l'idée de sonder la psychologie de jean
echenoz chose qui est un exercice ô
combien complexe mais je suis pas
persuadé qu'ils soient vraiment
convaincu qu'il peut l'emporter cette
fois ci en revanche s'il veut affermir
durablement y compris au cours du
quinquennat
son leadership sur l'ensemble dé gauche
mathieu c'est intéressant parce qu'il
vit en moi je ne me souviens n'est pas
qu'il ya cinq ans il avait déjà eu deux
des affiches comme celle là la
différence c'est le calendrier électoral
quand même il ya eu ces quinze jours où
il a pu être quasiment tous à la occuper
l'espace médiatique science est d'abord
sur le plan psychologique c'est que
d'habitude après les présidentielles
quand il perd jamais que gens sont
déprimés genre les portions fait la tête
et jean-luc match on se met un peu en
retrait là il a changé complètement
d'attitude puisque dès
l'entre-deux-tours il en ce slogan
bizarroïde d'un point de vue
institutionnel et mais qui fait mouche
parce que ya un désir de revanche et
comme le disait renault ça permet de
mobiliser les électeurs avec un bémol
quand même c'est que la sociologie
électorale quand on la regarde elle
n'est pas du tout favorable à jean luc
mélenchon et et ses proches le savent
bien c'est dire qu'en gros il sont pas
bien implantés sur tout le territoire
essentiellement dans des centres urbains
mais le reste du territoire pour voter
pour pour la france est soumise ou pour
la nuit ça sera plus compliqué d'autant
qu'un de ses parts dont les plus âgés
sont ceux qui votent le plus en france
quand vous avez le vote des plus âgés
vous avez une forme d'assurance quasi
tous risques c'est ce dont bénéficie
emmanuel macron est en revanche le vote
jeunes le vote populaire les gens qui se
sont portés sur jean luc mélenchon la
présidentielle sont pas des gens qui se
mobilisent généralement aux législatives
mais alors on va s'intéresser avec
alexandre tout ça au on va faire un peu
d'histoire au frais
union de la gauche alexandre aux écoutes
oui alors il ya bien sûr le front
populaire en 1936 mais on voulait
s'intéresser aux deux dernières union de
la gauche dans notre histoire politique
avec d'abord le programme commun des
années 70 en 1971 françois mitterrand
s'empare du parti socialiste lors du
congrès d'epinay et un an plus tard il
sait le programme commun de gouvernement
avec le parti communiste un programme
commun qui prévoit plusieurs mesures à
la semaine de travail à 39 heures la
retraite à 60 ans pour les hommes à 55
ans pour les femmes l'abolition de
l'habillement ou encore est la sortie de
l'otan et ce programme commun il a aussi
un objectif électoral car il permet aux
socialistes et aux communistes de
reprendre des couleurs à l'assemblée
nationale lors des législatives de 73 où
ils obtiennent près de cent soixante
quinze sièges à l'assemblée nationale un
programme commun qui est peu à peu
délaissé au fil du temps par françois
mitterrand et qui vole en éclats en 1977
sur fond de désaccord avec georges
marchais sur la défense nationale mais
en 1981 et bien cela n'empêchera pas le
président de la république françois
mitterrand d'intégrer des ministres
communistes dans son gouvernement et
plus récemment il ya quoi 25 ans il ya
la gauche plurielle évidemment et oui on
en 1997 il ya des élections législatives
puisque jacques chirac dissous
l'assemblée nationale et les partis de
gauche improvisant un accord électoral
socialiste et écologiste se mettre
d'accord sur quelques mesures de ce
programme de la gauche plurielle encore
une réduction du temps de travail
moratoire sur le nucléaire monnaie
unique sous conditions le rmi pour les
jeunes pour les 18 25 ans les
communistes font aussi partie de cette
gauche plurielle mais juste sur l'accord
électoral et cela marche puisque la
gauche plurielle remporté la majorité
des sièges à l'assemblée nationale
lionel jospin devient le chef d'un
gouvernement à dominante socialiste mais
où tous les partis de gauche sont
représentés et pour la petite histoire
c'est le socialiste jean christophe
cambadélis qui avait théorisé cette
union de la gauche plurielle le même qui
aujourd'hui refusent elles annulent
pleine réunion populaire écologique et
sociale mais c'est vrai que le rapport
de forces est un petit peu différent
pour les socialistes évidemment il a
changé merci beaucoup alexandre pour ces
détails marc lazar vous avez signé une
tribune dans le monde dans lequel vous
justement vous vous livrer à cet
exercice
comparaison est évidemment très
difficile les contextes politiques
internationaux sont très différents vous
vous dites l'union est un combat c'est
peut-être le fil rouge oui alors en fait
c'était une déclaration d'un dirigeant
communiste etienne façon juste après la
signature du programme commun dans un
comité central qui n'avaient pas été
rendues publiques et qui ensuite plus
des années plus tard a été rendue
publique c'est-à-dire ont signé un
accord avec les socialistes mais ça va
être un combat parce qu'évidemment
socialistes et communistes signé cet
accord avec la volonté de ce plu mais
réciproquement à plumer la volaille
socialiste pour les communistes formule
de l'une des parties comme les années 20
ème plumer la volaille communiste pour
françois mitterrand évidemment le
contexte est différent je trouve qu'on
voit quand même des éléments de
continuité alors la rupture c'est que ça
s'est fait cet accord cette fois ci en
quelques jours alors que le programme
comme un environnement remontons pas en
36 mais programme commun c'est vrai que
ça se signe en un an mais c'est le
résultat de dix années de travail entre
les partis socialiste le parti
communiste dix années de travail 1962 à
1972 et 97,6 un accord électoral qui
fait suite à deux années de travail par
le parti socialiste à partir de l'échec
de lionel jospin contre jacques chirac à
la présidentielle donc ça c'est la
première différence la deuxième c'est
qu'évidemment il ya des candidats unis
partout même s'il ya des dissidences qui
n'a jamais existé en 97 c'est un accord
juste avec les verts mais 22 ou 27
circonscriptions qui avait été accordé
par le socialiste au vert puis d'un
troisième caractère inédit et c'est vrai
historique de ce point de vue là
mélenchon a raison c'est que c'est
dominer cette alliance par la france
info me sert une gauche radicale il ya
des continuités dans le programme je
suis absolument frappé avoir regardé les
655 proposition de mélenchon que sur les
questions économiques et sociales
le retour du programme commun des années
70 c'est impressionnant c'est le retour
à l'état tout puissant il dit allons-y
pour les dépenses d'ailleurs
actuellement un certain nombre de
chercheurs sont en train d'évaluer ce
que ça représente en termes de dépenses
publiques la grande innovation là le
grand changement tout ne se reproduit
pas à l'identique c'est l'écologie ça
c'est fondamental et c'est ce qui a
attiré une partie des électorats jeunes
incontestablement c'est l'acte
l'insistance sur le l'outre-mer ça à
plusieurs reprises dans le programme qui
était très présente et et d'autre part
évidemment la 6ème république ça c'est
les innovations de ce programme qui par
ailleurs indiquent les nombreux points
de désaccords qui seront alors ya une
formule très belle tout ça sera remis à
la sagesse de l'assemblée nationale à
son extraordinaire cette formule
poétique lançant la plume de mélenchon
on en remet à la sagesse de l'assemblée
nationale qui devra on ne sait trop
comment régler les différends entre ces
différentes formations l'union juste
pour terminer à l'unité l'union s'est
pas limitée et à chaque fois que la
gauche s'est uni est là au bout d'un
moment quand elle arrive au gouvernement
elle s'est divisée ça a été le cas en
1936 ça a été le cas évidemment en 1981
puisque en 1984 et communistes sorte la
seule exception c'est vrai c'est la
gauche plurielle ils sont restés
ensemble pour différentes raisons
pendant cinq ans mais avec l'échec de
lionel jospin en 2002 sophie de ravenel
vous avez suivi pour le figaro bernard
cazeneuve qui est en rupture du du parti
socialiste évidemment venus soutenir la
candidate socialiste dissidente dans le
20e arrondissement à paris il affirme
dans ce lors de ce déplacement l'ancien
préau ministre qu'une autre gauche est
possible et alors ils ciblent jean luc
mélenchon c'est vraiment ça le le fil
rouge de cette campagne parce qu'il fait
campagne en ce moment bien là il fait
campagne en faveur d'une autre gauche
une autre gauche est possible il fait
campagne quand même il faut le dire
aussi contre jean luc mélenchon
évidemment ces mots sont très dur et
qu'on campagne aussi contre la direction
actuelle du ps en vue même s'il ne sera
pas candidat lui-même du prochain
congrès du ps là on n'est plus mon
histoire de solférino logis mais c'est
vrai que les socialistes vont être
appelés à renouveler a priori la
direction de leur parti s'il existe
encore à l'automne prochain
bon allez donc évidemment il se situe là
dedans plutôt pour carole delga dont il
est assez proche que pour d'autres
carole delga pas de patronne socialiste
de la région occitanie qui elle aussi
aujourd'hui mène un combat très fort en
faveur d'une autre gauche même si elle
n'est pas complètement en rupture de ban
avec le ps enfin disons plus ps ne l'a
pas encore exclue et bernard cazeneuve a
aussi un combat personnel contre
jean-luc mérite je cite on a vu la
situation que je l'a appelée du gauche
opposée à celle de jean luc mélenchon
tumultueuse qui préfèrent le vin car
nous trans la confrontation de tous
contre tous à la nécessité de trouver un
chemin qui rassemble c'est un portrait
de jean luc mélenchon en faible on les
actes eux mans et puis s'il a dénoncé
très fortement la façon avec laquelle
jean luc mélenchon associe les violences
à la police parce qu'évidemment en cire
ministre de l'intérieur grand défenseur
etc etc et c'est très intéressant ce cas
de la quinzième circonscription de paris
parce que on a comme candidat trois
anciens 3 ou socialiste ou ancien
socialiste on a moins un mètre gassama
qui était un ancien socialiste lui-même
adjoint de frédérique calandra qui fut
la maire du 20e avant de rejoindre
emmanuel macron et donc mohamed gassama
est là pour ensemble le candidat il fut
le socialiste grand défenseur de
françois hollande etc nous avons donc
lamiae rage qui incarne aujourd'hui le
parti socialiste plus ou moins d'ici
l'an même si le ps la soutient pas ce
qu'ils pouvaient pas faire autrement et
qu'elle est proche d'anne hidalgo qui ce
sont des tensions locales mais elle
était surtout candidat était députée
sortante de cet arrondissement et
danielle simonnet ancien socialiste
aussi très proche de jean luc mélenchon
conseillère de paris et
voilà et c'est tout un petit peu
l'histoire du ps qui se résuma dans
cette circonstance si tu sais quand même
passionnant alors il ya aussi mathieu le
flou réservé aux écologistes dans cette
nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale oui parce qu'on a
beaucoup compatit c'est pour socialiste
contraint de se faire hara kiri
idéologique avant de se faire avaler
tout cru par le grand méchant loup
mélenchon mais au bout du compte moi je
me pose la question parce que c'est pas
les écologistes ont le plus perdu dans
l'aventuré d'accord sur le papier ils
ont été les mieux servis sans
circonscription pour europe ecologie les
verts 69 pour le ps 50 pour le parti
communiste mais tout de même quand on
prend un peu de recul c'est bien simple
écologie politique a manqué son rendez
vous avec l'histoire avec un grand h une
fois de plus sont tentés de dire mais
cette fois ci pour être bien pourrait
bien être la dernière avant longtemps
pourquoi et pascal aurait cette
présidentielle il avait une fenêtre de
tir idéale qui à mon avis ne se
représentera pas de sitôt d'abord un
contexte ultra favorable avec une prise
de conscience des français sur la
nécessité de prendre des mesures pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique ou préserver l'environnement
c'était pas la première thématique mais
c'était dans le top 3 des préoccupations
des français en gros la présentielle
2022 devait se jouer sur leur terrain
deuxièmement il avait sur le plan
électoral le vent en poupe a été porté
par des bons scores aux européennes par
des conquêtes de grandes villes aux
municipales qui leur conférait une fois
montré une possibilité de leadership à
gauche dans cette gauche un peu qu'on
appelait la gauche du gouvernement la
gauche social-démocrate et puis enfin il
avait une ligne plus consensuelle avec
un candidat qui était peut-être pas le
plus spectaculaire mais qui avait le
mérite d'être un écologiste convaincu et
d'obédiences réaliste c'est à dire
capable de comprendre qu'il ya une
différence entre un compromis et une
compromission et que la décroissance ou
la restriction le faisait rêver personne
en clair une figure capable de séduire
au delà de son électorat traditionnel
écolo militants et aujourd'hui mais
aujourd'hui la présidentielle est passée
par là et comme dirait quelqu'un de
célèbre rien ne s'est passé comme prévu
les écolos n'ont pas su se montrer les
plus légitimes d'abord les plus
inventifs et les plus volontaristes sur
la transition écologique en ressortant
de ses archives socialiste le vieux
concept de planification mais jean-luc
mélenchon des amis cas au mieux ce
dernier est parvenu à incarner le vote
utile au premier tour à gauche
s'arrogeant une forme de leadership que
les écologistes vont bien avoir du mal à
contester dans les années qui viennent
il en veut au congo où ils vont passer
du statut de croupion du ps du temps de
la splendeur sur le ferry nien à celui
de supplétifs de la france insoumise
dans les temps qui viennent quant à la
ligne après avoir choisi sur le fil
l'option la plus rassembleuse dont je
parlais tout à l'heure celle de yannick
jadot ils se sont laissés emporter a
peut-être lui le premier en tout cas lui
a laissé faire par la radicalité de sa
rivale malheureuse sandrine rousseau
pire d'une certaine façon l'accord avec
les insoumis les prive de la dernière
chose qui leur faisait garder les pieds
sur terre c'est à dire leur lien à
l'europe et au à vos prises de
conscience du réel bref en rejoignant
les insoumis les écolos français ont
fait le choix d'abandonner des idées qui
rassemble pour se cantonner aux marges
qui clivent du sapin de noël recyclables
aux cantines s'engendre en passant par
le burqini dans les piscines en un mot
ils vont passer du grand bain au petit
vin est la seule question c'est de
savoir pour combien de temps met à
redire si vous êtes d'accord est ce que
les verts sont pour longtemps sur le
banc de touche sur le plan idéologique
je suis je suis d'accord ce que j'ai dit
à mathieu croissandeau parce que ce qui
est frappant c'est qu'effectivement d'un
point de vue idéologique là pour le coup
loupé à de jean luc mélenchon parce
qu'en fait ce qu'il a formidablement
réussi sur l'ensemble des gauchers une
opération capitalistique
extrêmement efficace et une au pea sur
le plan idéologique elle a
particulièrement réussi avec les verts
parce que si j'ose dire de verre et les
verts était dans le fruit est un peu
facile vous n'accordez à mais il y avait
déjà en fait une cinquième colonne
mélenchonistes au sein des verts portés
en particulier par sandrine rousseau qui
qui sur cette ligne radicale a fait
campagne contre yannick jadot pendant
toute la campagne présidentielle jusqu'à
d'ailleurs perdre son statut de
parti et qui ensuite donc a eu du mal à
accepter d'avoir perdu et qui sur une
des îles sur des points de clivage fort
a fait campagne contre yannick jadot
jusqu'à perdre son poste de porte parole
du candidat yannick jadot eric piolle
qui aujourd'hui promeut le port du
burkini dans les piscines municipales à
à grenoble en 2010 est faux souvenirs
qui les soutenaient jean luc mélenchon à
la présidentielle il était
mélenchonistes entière déjà toute une
frange des verts qui était acquise aux
insoumis donc effectivement d'un point
de vue idéologique et bien c'est au pea
et les parties en réussite sur le plan
comprend pourquoi d'ailleurs les verts
en quelque sorte se sont rendu sans
résister c'est parce que j'en avais
aucun sortant il n'avait pas député
sortant donc dès lors qu'ils obtiennent
un certain nombre de circonscriptions il
était prêt à aller dans cet accord pour
les socialistes pour ce qu'il reste des
socialistes c'est pour ça qu'on peut
peut-être plus douter de la pérennité de
cet accord au delà de législatives c'est
qu'il ya un vrai tête à queue
idéologique sur un certain nombre de
points qui ont été évoqués déjà depuis
blake en paix les initiatives mais qui
sont terribles pour les socialistes
verde la désobéissance au traité
européen la sortie de l'otan des
nationalisations massives de des banques
d'edf dungey des autos des aéroports
c'est pas simplement la négation du
quinquennat hollande avec par exemple
l'annulation l'abrogation de la loi elle
conneries ou le retour par exemple en 48
heures les socialistes étaient pour le
maintien de la retraite à 62 ans ils se
sont ralliés à la retraite à 60 ans pour
tous sa part fait un élan de débats au
sein de ce qui reste du ps mais c'est
aussi un retour avant même les années
jospin parce que le quinquennat jospin
était celui qui a le plus privatisé au
cours de ces 30 dernières années donc
pour les socialistes on peut imaginer ce
qui explique la la stratégie de bernard
cazeneuve jeu pas si l'huile à une
quelconque ambition personnelle ça aussi
c'est un mystère de longue date mais on
peut imaginer qu'il ya encore un pôle de
résistance en tout cas un centre de
sociaux démocrates attachés à ces
positions à qu'ils veuillent après
législatives essayer en tout cas de
retrouver un petit peu d'oxygène alors
qu'elle dit devis vous donner à cette
cette nouvelle union marc lazar parce
que dans la prochaine assemblée on peut
tout à fait imaginer alors c'est
l'objectif que chacun partitionner parti
communiste europe écologie verts la
france insoumise s'il passe le seuil des
15 députés ils vont créer leur groupe
enfin voyez ce que veut dire chacun va
peut-être reprendre un peu son autonomie
mais ça va au delà de ça c'est même
l'habilité de mélenchon cette fois ci
parce qu'en 2017 il avait pas voulu
faire ça et cette fois ci il l'a fait ce
père qu'il a donné cette concession à
ses alliés de pouvoir s'ils ont plus de
15 à lui avoir des cons parlementaire il
a tout de suite dit attention il y aura
un groupe interparlementaire pour
essayer de contrôler les différentes
formations je pense que toutes les
tensions et toutes tes contradictions
vont éclater au grand jour et ce sera
très compliqué la marge de manoeuve cela
dit et ce qu'on peut penser tout de
suite le parti comme les communistes une
partie des verts une partie des
socialistes ont essayé de retrouver un
peu leur autonomie et vont dire on a
fait cet accord il ya d'autres échéances
qui vont arriver pour lesquelles on est
mieux préparé parce que c'est des
échéances locales écrire en même temps
si cette dynamique unitaire fonctionne
ce sera dur d'apparaître comme des
diviseurs de la dynamique unitaire et ça
c'est je crois le jeu auquel pense jean
luc mélenchon pour l'avenir c'est à dire
vous rompez maintenant mais alors vous
en portez la responsabilité
et rappelez vous c'est quelqu'un qui a
comme modèle françois mitterrand et
lorsque a été rappelé la rupture en
1977-1978 du programme commun qui en
fait une rupture liés à la fois au parti
communiste et au parti socialiste la
grande habilité de mitterrand a été dire
mais moi je suis unitaire pour nos jeux
le continuerait alors que le parti
communiste français n'a pas arrêté de
tirer à boulet rouge sur françois
mitterrand et mélenchon va continuer a
dit ressentir je suis la figure de
l'unité et vous diviser cela dit je
pense que élan les verts et dans le
parti socialiste il y aura de multiples
ruptures mathieu un monde jusque vers un
choc de cultures sur qui prend la
décision et comment on prend la décision
parce qu'on a quand même deux mondes
complètement différents on a un parti la
france a soumises ou n'y a pas de
culture du vote on est dans un principe
d'acclamations enfin faut le lire on a
un parti socialiste qu'à une future du
vote réel sur des textes sur des
orientations qui on a des écologistes
qui ont une culture du vente sur le vote
serré se prennent des décisions et ça va
clasher à un moment parce que
si on ne peut pas assis et si ya pas de
vote sur les grandes orientations sur
les grandes décisions dans ce hameau
intergroupe et même dans la stratégie
globale ça va être très fière que la
seule façon très vite pour pour créer la
nuque il va bien falloir que les
éléments qu'on pas été tranchée parce
qu'on n'avait pas le temps le soin après
ca c'est un peu ça le juste en moins
sucrés dur mais c'est quoi selon lui la
seule formation dure qui n'a pas ratifié
par un vote cet accord c'est
ce sont les insoumis ce sont des
cellules ce que l'on s'aime on se
souvient du vote des verbes en soutien
du côté des socialistes c'est le seul de
nos seuls cas où il n'y a pas une fois
donc c'est ça pourrait être lâché très
vite effectivement
dans un cas de figure les bailleurs de
ce qui pourrait leur avait cédé que
c'est d'arriver au pouvoir parce que ce
qui fédère ce qui fédère ces gauches en
fait c'est emmanuel macron oui c'est
l'anti ma chronique sur ce programme
commun minimal si j'ose dire ils seront
toujours d'accord mais si jamais demain
effectivement cette alliance arrivée au
pouvoir la ces désaccords de fond qui
sont comme le rappelait marc lazar noté
de façon extrêmement pudique dans cet
accord mis en quarantaine a quand même
ses désaccords donc remis à la sagesse
de l'assemblée c'est pas sur des sujets
mineurs c'est sur le champ des
nationalisations c'est sur la sortie de
l'otan c'est sur les livraisons d'armes
à l'ukraine c'est sur la désobéissance
aux traités européens c'est pas sur des
sujets secondaires évidemment si cette
coalition accéder au pouvoir là on peut
douter de sa capacité à rester
durablement unis sophie d'origine elle
susurre justement c'est cette recette
ans est en jeu fin à la fois les lignes
de rupture et la clarification
obligatoires oui je ne peux qu'être
d'accord avec vous tous réunis ici il ya
juste une chose c'est peut-être de voir
si jamais il devenait le premier
intergroupe d'opposition premier groupe
d'opposition là il y aurait quand même
un enjeu à rester unis pour conserver ce
poids évidemment face à emmanuel macron
je pense qu'ils peuvent évidemment en
plus du choix des français de la volonté
qui a été exprimée on l'a dit on l'a
redit un d'avoir cette unité de la
gauche aussi artificielle soit elle il
ya cette volonté au parlement de rester
ce premier groupe d'opposition avec
évidemment la commission des finances
même si on ne sait pas trop qui d'eric
coquerel ou de valérie rabault les deux
n'ayant pas coquerel l'insoumis et
rabaud la socialiste n'est pas n'ayant
pas exactement les mêmes options en
matière de finances mais il va y avoir
des discussions entre et c'est vrai que
ça s'apprend parce que ils vont vouloir
incarner cette opposition conserver
parce que là jean luc mélenchon l'a
obtenu la gagner il est le principal
opposant de jean-luc mélenchon
il a souligné sur demande de la
psychologie de jean luc mélenchon est
compliqué à analyser mais de fait
premier opposant d'emmanuel macro
évidemment et dans cette campagne on le
sent on sent comme une tension au sein
de l'exécutif dans la majorité même si
effectivement on l'a tous souligné ils
sont en tête dans les sondages mais en
projection sur les voies évidemment
c'est plus compliqué
souligne ça fait six sondages de suite
que nous sommes en tête etc c'est un
signe pour l'instant on n'y est pas
encore on est loin de là mais si c'est
un siège alors que les sondages se sont
toujours trompés à la non mais il a
évidemment ça les arrange mais de fait
il est quand même jean luc mélenchon il
a obtenu d'être le premier opposant
d'emmanuel maquereau a eu une réaction
tout de suite sur la question cette
gauche peut-elle prendre le pouvoir
évidemment
l'ancien président de la république
françois hollande répond par la négative
c'est vrai qu'à 2 gauche et c'est tout à
fait conciliable noël sont pas
irréconciliables les électeurs veulent
même leur union il ya une gauche qui
radical ont emprunté par le parti
communiste aujourd'hui par jean luc
mélenchon et une gauche qui réformiste
quand la gauche réformiste est plus
forte que la gauche radicale elle permet
à toute la gauche d'arriver au pouvoir
pas forcément dit rester d'ailleurs et
quand la gauche radicale est plus forte
mais c'est le cas aujourd'hui que la
gauche réformiste et qu'elle ne fait pas
l'effort du compromis eh bien elle ne
parvient pas au pouvoir et c'est ça le
problème que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui marc lazar est ce que cette
gauche radicale reprend les termes de
françois hollande finalement guide ou
même ses électeurs dans une impasse
politique il n'a pas tort le président
françois hollande en même temps cette
opposition entre une gauche radicale et
gauche réformiste il faut la nuance et
beaucoup parce que justement la
particularité du parti socialiste était
d'avoir deux âmes au minimum de
sensibilité dont une plutôt réformiste
incontestablement et une autre toujours
un peu radical et un certain nombre de
socialistes se reconnaissent dans cette
culture de l'égalité pour ne pas dire de
l'égalitarisme de ce retour à l'état etc
alors oui en france historiquement
lorsque la gauche radicale et plus
puissante effectivement n'a jamais
réussi à accéder au pouvoir je remarque
cela dit que jean luc mélenchon essaye
de modérer son discours en 1 de se
donner une stature justement d'hommes
responsables en partie aura évidemment
s'il était premier ministre à matignon
il a dit attention je veillerai pas au
clash avec emmanuel macron il envoie une
série de messages enterre déjà son
projet d'une certaine façon oui il ya un
autre élément moi je crois sur lequel il
joue mais c'est classique 1 pour ces
élections c'est de dire il y aura un
mouvement social et on va tout faire
pour qu'un mouvement social d'abord si
on gagne on va s'appuyer sur le
mouvement social moi je leur tends dû à
plusieurs reprises de la part de
mélenchonistes avec le modèle 1936 en
quoi historiquement ils se trompent
parce que je suis déjà en 2017 il avait
parié sur une mobile millions de
personnes dans la rue il y avait eu
alors justement est là et c'est ici on
perd meilleur un quatrième tour ce sera
le mouvement social à la rentrée parce
que la situation sociale va se dégrader
encore plus et on sera au rendez vous
mais effectivement ces invocations et
ses appels en général au moins ne sont
pas suivies mais cesser leurs idées et
je pense que cette idée de l'invocation
social c'est pour essayer justement de
rendre prisonnier les autres formations
en disant il faudra bien vous nous
suiviez voilà donc et je sais bien
qu'ils rejettent les institutions de la
vème république mais c'est quand même
une façon de ne jamais accepter le
résultat d'une élection c'est aussi lors
du temps il ya une délégitimation des
associations d'un des taux d'abstention
qui sont massifs on a vu aussi des
manifestations qui parfois pour une
frange basculé dans la violence il a
conscience de ce paysage l'a1 qu'il
essaye aussi de s'en faire le jeu
reprend le titre de votre livre renaud
dély anatomie d'une trahison la gauche
contre le progrès est ce que là est ce
que ça vaut pour pour cette nouvelle
union populaire est ce qu'elle est
contre le progrès pour tous en un sens
oui parce que je pense qu'il ya toute
une frange de la gauche qui du fait de
la complexité hambourg durel et de son
incapacité à le transformer a changé
quand elle est au pouvoir et compris
c'est aussi une des conséquences de
l'échec de la gauche au pouvoir sous le
quinquennat de france aux langues parce
que l'art en grande partie baisser les
bras s'est réfugié dans une forme
d'illusion c'est à dire dans le sa
volonté de ressusciter effectivement des
recettes des années soixante dix où des
années 80 ddd conviction soit disant pur
proclamé comme tel justement et et
brandir l'étendard de la vraie gauche il
ya toujours celui qui est plus à gauche
qui est plus pur et c'est à l'opposition
à prendre social traître à la gauche
molle etc sauf que ses convictions là
sont d'une part souvent date est
obsolète ces outils h pas par exemple on
a évoqué le vaste programme de
nationalisations et et sont souvent on
déporte cette gauche on va dire les
cartes du centre de gravité de l'opinion
marc lazar a raison de rappeler que les
socialistes ont été aussi dans le passé
traversé par ces radicalité parfois sauf
que après 1980 et la conquête du pouvoir
sur un programme qui était effectivement
radical il ya eu en 1983 c'est à dire
que très vite au contact du règne
justement cette gauche elle a été
obligée de changer on va dire et le
problème de ce programme me semble-t-il
c'est que en gros soit
jean luc mélenchon l'appliquent et là
les conséquences en tout cas sur le plan
économique et financier et pas seulement
sur le plan international aussi pour la
france sont passés vertigineuse soit
d'emblée effectivement il est obligé de
renoncer à un certain nombre de points
il ya un cas en europe sous la gauche
radicale est arrivé au pouvoir c'est la
grèce c'est syriza en 2015 et très
rapidement alexis tsipras ce qu'était
prémices grec de l'époque a adjuré on va
dire sa promesse de sortir l'union
européenne et de l'euro parce
qu'effectivement son pays s'était pas du
tout l'intérêt de la grèce à l'époque de
sortir de l'union européenne les deux
robes le mur du real match jusque est
paradoxal c'est cette radicalisation à
gauche c'est exactement ce que
souhaitait madame mâcon la main paysage
il croisera d'égaliser gauche
radicaliser parce qu'ils jugent qu'elles
seront sociologiquement toujours
minoritaire dans le paysage politique
français et donc qu'il n'y a aucun
risque pour le gros bloc central libéral
qu'il a constitué et il ya un autre
point c'est une exception européenne
mais c'est une exception européenne dire
d'avoir un parti socialiste qui a
quasiment disparu du cas au niveau
national il ya deux autres pays en
europe c'est la grèce 1 le pasok
s'effondrait même si revient maintenant
il a recréé tout une coalition de centre
gauche et c'est les pays bas sinon le
paradoxe de l'inspection de la gauche
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle revient au
pouvoir dans beaucoup de pays européens
où l'élite au pouvoir dans la péninsule
ibérique en espagne au portugal en
allemagne dans les pays scandinaves aux
arguments d'un dany d'algos pendant la
confiance est là résume ce point de vue
là du point de vue du constat ils ont
même gagné les travaillistes en
australie bon et donc parce que il ya
effectivement une situation dans le cas
il ya des conjonctures il ya des cycles
historiques dans lequel effectivement il
ya des besoins de protection important
est là et la gauche sociale démocrate
réformiste incarné et là en france on
est dans une exception mais vraiment une
singularité et satie stupéfie chez les
jeunes actifs reste les partis de gauche
en ans sauf hardy d'abord et ensuite ça
va pas durer je pensais c'est
intéressant ce que vous disiez parce que
effectivement emmanuel macron a réussi
ce pari là mais quid de l'après macron
de la succession on est dans un court
terme on n'est pas dans la grande
histoire de la gauche sous les yeux de
là on est donc le pari des
sociaux-démocrates aujourd'hui bernard
cazeneuve carole delga même françois
hollande et d'autres c'est de se dire
bon de toute façon ça ne va pas durer
puisque emmanuel macron il est seul il
n'a pas vraiment de formation et déjà
autour de lui se prépare sa succession
la guerre de ne savoir qui va prendre
son héritage mais est-ce qu'il y aura un
héritage politique est-ce qu'on va
rester dans cette tripartition qui la
range aujourd'hui c'est une grande
question et c'est le pari des
sociaux-démocrates que ce ne sera pas le
cas mais c'est vrai comme le dit marc
lazar que la gauche quand elle revient
au pouvoir en europe c'est parce que
justement elle a adapté son logiciel
qu'elle ait tenu compte d'un certain
nombre d'évolutions du grain que ce soit
en allemagne où c'est une coalition
comme les sociaux démocrates sont alliés
aux verts mais aussi aux libéraux que ce
soit en espagne au portugal qui étaient
des pays qui avaient été plongés dans la
crise financière après le krach 2009 à
son terrible et les coalitions de gauche
ont contribué aussi à la fois à réformer
le pays mais à restaurer les finances
publiques ou dans les pays scandinaves
où sont souvent sur des sujets régaliens
que les sociaux démocrates notamment au
danemark ont changé d'approché et c'est
vrai que c'est pas ce qui se produit en
france du tout et d'ailleurs quand jean
luc mélenchon va puiser une référence à
l'étranger il la puise jamais un enfant
puisqu'elle n'existe pas il va en avril
chaque fois modèle radicalement
différent que ce soit d'un point de vue
historique sociologique sociale et
politique marc lazar entendre pour
conclure il nous reste deux trois
minutes pourquoi jean luc mélenchon ne
se présentent pas aux législatives j'ai
quand même du mal à comprendre parce que
il se prive d'une tribune
et donc il ya plusieurs hypothèses où il
est alors dit on fatigue et moi j'y
crois pas je crois qu'il est en pleine
forme vous l'avez vu moi je n'ai pas vu
mes donc
je crois qu'à une autre hypothèse c'est
de prendre un peu de distance est-ce que
je crois que contrairement à ce qu'on
pense il pense à la prochaine échéance
et qu'abidal seront opposés pour
baden a été lu à 79 ans alors je sais
qu'il prend pas tellement c'est exemple
aux états unis
c'est donc pourquoi pas c'est à dire de
prendre de prendre une stature d'état
aux dom l'état véritablement de ne plus
être le mélenchon qui eurent la
république c'est moi de se taper avec la
justice et et la police d'insultés votre
profession à plusieurs reprises et
justement de d'avoir une certaine
distance sage le vieux sage d'avoir
contre cette coalition d'accuser
justement tous ceux qui voudront sortir
en disant mais regardez on a créé une
dynamique unitaire certes on n'a pas pu
gagner cette fois ci mais ma progression
est incontestable et puis pour parce
qu'il ya un gros problème à la france
insoumise d'ailleurs c'est ce qui me
semble très intéressant sur les trois
formations aux principales la france un
soumise à un gros problème de succession
là aussi emmanuel macron vous l'avez dit
même si les socialistes l'erreur des
socialistes depuis 2010 est cette pensée
comme un conte est un épiphénomène un
bon donc mais et et puis même le
rassemblement national qu'est ce que va
devenir marine le pen donc là on est
dans un processus très incertain et
peut-être plutôt que d'essayer
d'organiser sa succession view mieux
vaut prendre de la distance et de se
construire cette figure du vieux
responsable sage expérimentés qui
donnera de temps en temps quelques
indications et qu'il cultivera le
quasiment culte alors on a des
chercheurs qui travaillent notamment
dans dans la banlieue vers vernier qui
qu'ils m'expliquent des chercheurs en
sciences po et ils font un travail de
terrain d'observation qui est une sorte
de culte de la personnalité dont parmi
les jeunes issus notamment de
l'immigration et de confession musulmane
des notions presque embrasser le
portrait de mélenchon mais pas allés
voter pour des élections initiative cas
là on va conclure là dessus merci
beaucoup merci à tous participer à ce
débat je rappelle le titre de vos livres
alors marc lazar il ya l'histoire du
parti communiste français publié aux
presses universitaires de france et puis
des socialistes européens et l'état
c'est aux éditions de l'aube
je sais pas si on les voit mais c'est
pas grave renaud dély anatomie d'une
trahison la gauche contre le progrès
c'est aux éditions de l'observatoire